en janvier de l'an dernier l'émergence
de mots rien dans la recherche
névralgique de l'intelligence
artificielle se précisait par une
annonce majeure de l'entreprise
microsoft car dans des doublés alors la
taille de la jeune entreprise
montréalaise malou bas pour accélérer la
conception de logiciels permettant aux
ordinateurs de lire écrire et même de
tenir des conversations manière
naturelle
puis printemps dernier facebook a
annoncé l'ouverture d'un laboratoire de
recherche en intelligence artificielle à
montréal puis en septembre
le bloc furent institute confirmait que
c'est à montréal que l'on retrouve un la
plus forte concentration d'emplois 220
milles dans le secteur de la haute
technologie au canada une des
entreprises phares et éléments à
l'étoile montante dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle sur la scène
internationale toutes les entreprises
peu importe le domaine à bénéficier des
avancées d'intelligence
philippe beaudoin vice président
principal du groupe de recherche
d'éléments à l'épicentre de
l'intelligence artificielle ces temps ci
avec probablement le plus grand
laboratoire de recherche dans le domaine
au real le millas et nous on est très
très bien connecté avec l'excellent
boulot donc on est en mesure de prendre
des avancées les plus récentes et d'en
faire bénéficier les entreprises
rapidement
philippe beaudoin a choisi de quitter
google pour devenir vice président
principal du groupe de recherche de la
compagnie a eu avec entre autres le
professeur yoshua bengio de l'université
de montréal qui lui est considéré comme
une sommité mondiale une des rockstars
manganèse dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage profond niveau de
représentation
plusieurs niveaux d'abstraction c'est
quelque chose qui est à démarrer le fer
de lance des progrès des dernières
semaines
c'est quelque chose qui risque de
transformer la société aujourd'hui si
vous avez intelligent par exemple
utilisent profond 2012 pour la
reconnaissance pour
la reconnaissance de tout ce qui est
visuel donc les visages par exemple les
collections de photos les les objets on
peut regarder un objet avec téléphone
que la caméra puis vous reconnaissiez
dessus il ya beaucoup de développement
industriel qui sont autour de ces
technologies là puis quelque chose qui
est en train d'évoluer aussi puisqu'on
retrouve aussi dans téléphone c'est la
capacité de l'ordre à comprendre le sens
de ce que vous dites donc de pouvoir
converser avec vous l'euro de montréal
plateforme mondiale de l'intelligence
artificielle et de l'apprentissage
profond s'appuie maintenant sur une
série de chercheurs vedette mais aussi
sur une série d'initiatives privées
notamment le syntec l'incubateur
d'entreprises mis sur pied par l'école
de technologie supérieure de montréal le
directeur du syntec échangé ni qu'on
appelle propulsion selon matthieu dugal
animateurs de la sphère à radio canada
montréal est aux premières loges
maintenant une transformation radicale
de la société
plusieurs spécialistes abonde dans ce
sens parle la quatrième révolution
industrielle
on est véritablement actuellement à
montréal au québec
aux premières loges d'une transformation
radicale de la société on est dans un
degré d'amplitude qui est de comparable
à celui qu'on a connu avec l'invention
de l'imprimerie l' on est vraiment là
dans le livre les mutations que ça va
engendrer dans le domaine du monde du
travail dans leurs rapports aussi à
l'autre parce que ces intelligences
artificielles on veut entrer en
communication avec elle
elles vont nous tromper aussi parce
qu'elles vont nous montrer
on se souvient du film ce magnifique
film où donc joaquin phoenix tombe en
amour avec une voix on n'est pas loin de
ce donc c'est des mises en garde c'est
des fascinations aussi mais c'est aussi
on y est on a la chance d'être aux
premières loges ici actuellement à
montréal et au québec de cette
révolution l'up l'intelligence
artificielle développé à montréal
s'apprête elle à bouleverser le marché
du travail en envoyant des milliers de
québécois au chômage assurez vous
indique joël pinaud professeur associé à
l'école d'informatique d'une merci de
montréal en a vécu plusieurs autres
bouleversements si on pense au début du
20e siècle
40% je crois des américains était dans
l'agriculture à la fin du xxème siècle
c'était 4 % qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture et puis pendant ce cycle
en plus de cette transformation ne toute
l'entrée des femmes sur le marché du
travail qu'on a réussi à absorber ce
changement-là cette nouvelle population
travailleurs plutôt dans de nos emplois
la fin du siècle était plus bas je crois
que la nature humaine étant ce qu'elle
est on a une capacité de se réinventer
et ça va ça va changer ça sera plus des
camionneurs pas des gens qui font du
taxi mais il va avoir plusieurs autres
choses intéressantes qui vont sortir de
somme
un reportage de radio canada
international